hello everyone it is 5 30 a.m right now
um i happen to be awake and
what i would guess is some of the
biggest gaming news that will come out
of this entire year or potentially has
come out of several years prior has just
dropped i was sitting alone in my
apartment when i read this tweet and
just went
what
um so xbox tweeted today is a historic
moment we are excited to announce that
the world-renowned franchises and
talented people at atvi underscore ab
which is activision blizzard will be
joining team xbox full announcement
details here and then they have an image
um
saying xbox plus activision blizzard
king showing overwatch diablo call of
duty world of warcraft candy crush and
starcraft um but it also includes
treyarch toys for bob
i always forget about them
um a whole bunch of companies so if we
read the post here this is my first time
reading this i
basically live reaction to an xbox wire
story
um
okay uh this is welcoming the incredible
teams and legendary franchises of
activision blizzard to microsoft gaming
by phil spencer ceo of microsoft gaming
january 18
2022 at 5 25 a.m
the post says creators of call of duty
warcraft candy crush tony hawk diablo
overwatch spyro hearthstone guitar hero
crash bandicoot starcraft and more
join team xbox
as a team we are on a mission to extend
the joy and community of gaming to
everyone on the planet we all know that
gaming is the most vibrant and dynamic
form of entertainment worldwide and
we've experienced the power of social
connection and friendship that gaming
makes possible as we pursue that mission
it is incredibly exciting to announce
that microsoft has agreed to acquire
activision blizzard over many decades
the studios and teams that act that make
up activision blizzard have earned vast
wellsprings of joy and respect for
billions of people all over the world we
are incredibly excited to have the
chance to work with amazing talented
dedicated people across activision
blizzard
sorry activision publishing blizzard
entertainment binox demon ware digital
legends high moon studios infinity ward
king major league gaming radical
entertainment raven software
sledgehammer games toys for bob treyarch
and every team across activision
blizzard until this transaction closes
activision blizzard and microsoft gaming
will continue to operate independently
once the deal is complete the activision
blizzard businesses will report to me as
ceo of microsoft gaming and that is
something about this that i think is
very interesting that we will get to
when i finish reading the post
upon close we will offer as many
activision blizzard games as we can
within xbox game pass and pc game pass
both new titles and games from
activision blizzard's incredible catalog
we also announced today that game pass
now has more than 25 million subscribers
as always we look forward to continuing
to add more value and more great games
to game pass the fantastic franchises
across activision blizzard will also
accelerate our plans for cloud gaming
allowing more people in more places
around the world to participate in the
xbox community using phones tablets
laptops and other devices you already
own activision blizzard games are
enjoyed on a variety of platforms and we
plan to continue to support those
communities moving forward
that's interesting
hmm
that that's a sentence that you've
intentionally written
and and would imply to me that they will
continue to exist on playstation i
wouldn't have guessed that they would
otherwise but you wrote that on purpose
maybe we'll find out more or whatever i
would have assumed that they would not
continue to be on playstation as a
company microsoft is committed to our
journey for inclusion in every aspect of
gaming among both employees and players
oh i'm very glad that this is the part
that i wanted to talk about that there's
a note on this okay
as a company microsoft is committed to
our journey for inclusion in every
aspect of gaming among both employers
and players we deeply value individual
studio cultures we also believe that
creative success and autonomy go hand in
hand with treating every person with
dignity and respect we will hold all
teams and all leaders to this commitment
we're looking forward to extending our
culture of proactive inclusion to the
great teams at activision blizzard what
a delicate way
to phrase
to phrase
we are indeed aware that activision
blizzard is currently involved in a
lawsuit because they have been treating
employees absolutely terribly
um
interesting
around the world there is no more
exciting venue for fun and connection
than video games i agree and there has
never been a better time to play than
right now as we extend the joy and
community to gaming of gaming sorry to
everyone we look forward to welcoming
all of our friends at activision
blizzard to microsoft gaming and then it
has the gaming leadership team a little
breakdown of who is in charge of xbox
this is always a very interesting thing
to look into for the record if you're
someone who's interested in
you know
actually understanding how companies
operate is if you look at the
backgrounds of these people if you you
take anyone who's on a leadership team
of any board of any company and you see
what the individual people on the board
what their experience is or what their
resumes look like you can kind of get a
pretty good idea of what a company's
goals are a lot of time which i have not
done for the xbox leadership team to be
clear
um
i would like to get out of this image
uh so yeah wow super unexpected
did not see that coming um would never
have guessed uh
just like
they bought
one of the biggest publishers that's
ever existed you know
that is wild it's like i also would have
thought that you know ea was never up
for grabs um
but uh maybe things are changing um
obviously playstation is also making a
lot of acquisitions recently i feel like
we're seeing new ones every few months
um that this is yeah i just didn't
expect this one at all and i feel like
it is an especially interesting time to
purchase
act a blizz as it were because of the
current lawsuits and um because of bobby
kotek's current reputation um
i would not say that they are a
particularly favored publisher right now
they have allegations of
pretty major sexual harassment uh sexual
assault
um some pretty terrible crunch
conditions like things that i feel like
you can't ignore and again that i feel
like they tried to kind of fulfill tried
to kind of touch on
here so i don't know how that works
legally i don't know if that means that
microsoft will eventually inherit part
of the lawsuit or anything like that um
i wonder if that went into
you know this deal was clearly there
were structural changes that needed to
happen and activision blizzard and maybe
that opened them up to a conversation
they may not have been willing to have
prior um clearly they do need some
changes so that they stopped treating
their employees terribly that is
definitely something that they need and
uh
i i mean i've never heard of xbox
having any negative reputation where
that's concerned i did work at xbox
about 10 years ago
they were great to me um but i i don't
know and i think that you know that
seems like such a thing to to walk into
what it sounds like right now
um
based on this until the transaction
closes activision blizzard and microsoft
gaming will continue to operate
independently once the deal is complete
the activision blizzard business will
report to me as ceo of microsoft gaming
what does that mean for bobby kotick
does he has he lost his job is he going
somewhere finally um
because it seems like
bobby kotick not only is he in
jeffrey epstein's book
named with his email address spelt wrong
actually but it's definitely him um
which is very strange
uh
but he he also is like one of the
highest earning ceos by a dramatic
margin and activision blizzard
underneath him has had one of the
largest pay disparities as in the amount
of money that he earned versus the um
like average income for the people below
him uh is one of the worst in the entire
industry
um and they also have like a lot of
layoffs um all the time uh
so i know a lot of people who work at
activision blizzard and i hope that they
feel positively about this because
that's that's sort of what i'm hoping
comes out of it i feel like i'm thinking
about the human impact more so than
the uh console wars impact that i think
a lot of people probably cover here but
i'm like damn
just
i hope that
that they can fix things for the people
there um but no way of knowing
how any of that works right now and
obviously i'm recording this immediately
after seeing the news so i don't know if
more will probably break over the next
day
um of course the console thing is always
an interesting thing to talk about
i
yeah i
i'm surprised that they they said
activision blizzard games are enjoyed on
a variety of platforms and we plan to
continue to support those communities
moving forward i don't know what that
means i'm sure we'll
we'll find out but um
very very very interesting wow just had
such a strong reaction to it that i was
like i should just sit down and record
this anyway why not i'm already here so
that's what i'm doing uh have a
wonderful day everyone let me know what
you think
just yeah didn't see that one comment uh
i will see you guys next time bye